my name is fievel monev i'm a developer
on the python tools for visual studio
team with microsoft and today i'd like
to talk to you about the challenges in
debugging python and c and c++ and other
native killed side-by-side and what can
we do and what did we do to make this
experience much better so first of all
let me briefly recap how you actually
get in this situation in the first place
so why would you want to do this sort of
thing well there are two main scenarios
that we have identified the first one is
you have your Python code and your
writing extension modules of your
calling from your Python code the more
just written in C C++ sometimes more
exotic stuff like Fortran and the main
reason why people do it is to improve
perv you need you have some particular
expensive computation and python is just
not good enough for that or maybe you're
just wrapping a library that's ready
written and C or C++ you need to call it
to avoid we're writing it from scratch
and the other pretty common scenario is
you have a native application and you
hosting Python to provide some scripting
ability for your users so you know
sublime text my a lot of other desk
products actually do that pretty common
too so there are some other less common
scenarios like we have customers who do
who write a application viewer Fortran
and they use Python to unit test that
for instance but those are the main two
so for today I'm it's actually pretty
similar in terms of how you work with
that stuff so for today I'm going to use
the first scenario as a demo and I
decided to take an actual real-world
code to the bug so this is the beta ray
library this isn't pypy it's on github
it's open source exactly what the name
says it's backed bit arrays arbitrary
length fast bitwise operations actually
faster than numpy so if you have any to
try it out it's mostly written in C with
a little bit of Python glue code and it
has unit tests in Python and we'll use
those to explore the debugging of both
side by side
okay so let's debug this and see how
this works so first of all I'm going to
start with showing how this works
typically today with visual studio
second okay
should should make the texel bit larger
for the audience okay give me a second
okay so here we have our our unit tests
and I'm going to show that i have a
project in visual studio for this
particular library so have my my python
project i have my c++ project for the
native code here's a see file and here
our unit tests so i want to debug the
particular code path that creates a bit
array from a python list and we actually
have a unit test with here and i'm going
to set a breakpoint at this line which
calls the constructor and just start
debugging and it will take a couple
seconds for it to start and hit the
break point
so here we are so far so good we're in
Python we can see the call stack we can
see our locals now if I wanted to debug
this function call I can't just step
into it because it's also see code if I
were to do it the idea would just step
over so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to take another instance of visual
studio and I need to make this bigger as
well and set a breakpoint here and I
need to know in advance where I'm going
to end up when I make this call so
luckily for us already investigated this
I know that we are going to end and
it'll rain you so I'm just set a
breakpoint here and I'll go back to the
other one and i'll do a step over oh
sorry let's try that again i forgot to
teach my second ide so this is one good
example actually why this is not a
particular smooth process you basically
have to juggle two IDs and keep them
sink so here's a break one again and I'm
going to go to attach and beyond to find
whiten and here we go okay and I'm
stepping over and here i am in native
code in my function and i want to see
what's actually going on here so again
but my call stack I've got my variables
except what exactly can i glean out of
this the problem here is i see a bunch
of stuff if i can expire i can expand
them and i see just a bunch of c structs
looking at them there's no clue as to
what this thing actually is and this is
the function arguments so it's kind of
important I can figure out that there
was a tuple I could write a bunch of C
casts to actually see what's inside and
probably have to write like three or
four not very convenient and if I were
to go back to my other ide the the one
that's divided in Python I can't see
anything here because as far as its
concerned the program is to running I
don't see a whole stack I don't see the
locals I be
tically I'm locked out and if I wanted
to go back well my only option is really
to continue to bug in here and now I'm
back in my Python code and I can
actually see what I've passed except now
I lost my native context so it kind of
works if you need to use it but
unfortunately not as good as we'd like
so to summarize debugging Python and
sleep a spot at the same time is
complicated messy process you don't want
to do it if you have if you can avoid it
you have to teach to the buggers they're
not aware of each other so you can only
use one at a time and actually you can
break things in pretty bad way because
of that option including crushing one
debugger with the other if you're
particularly not careful so we really
wanted to do is make a better way with
an integrated single debugger experience
that's completely aware of both sides
and that takes care of all that for you
so let me show you how this works sorry
okay let's get back to our debuggers and
i'm going to stop everything here i'm
going to stop everything here and i'm
going to go and take this check box now
let's try that again so i'll get started
a bug in and i'll wait for the
breakpoint to hit it's going to take a
little bit longer because this time we
are doing build things at the same time
and it makes stuff unfortunately a
little bit slower than I'd like but here
we are and now instead of doing all this
all these shenanigans with attaching I'm
just going to step in here we go so we
have ended up directly no native code I
didn't have to know what it is I didn't
have to send any break points and if you
look at what we actually see here and
ticular the call stack you can actually
see that it has the
the Python frames still here and it has
a transition so i can switch back and I
can still see where I came from I can
still inspect the variables and I can
switch back to to my seat code and i can
again expand variables and interesting i
fuse if i scroll down to the very bottom
you can see that it actually it also has
the the other way around because python
itself is a native application right
hosting the interpreter so it
transitioned into python code so now
this is much more interesting but we
still have this little nagging issue
that we don't actually know what args is
exactly and we could go I'll up the
stack and basically figure out but there
is a better way now I'm have this magic
menu here and I'm going to do this and
I'm going to expand our X and look at
that so we actually have the Python
presentation of the subject complete
with the type i can expand it i can
expand the elements and interesting
enough i can even change things so there
we go and of course I can still do
everything I normally do in native code
so you know I can I can step over
sayings i can still set breakpoints i
can run to break points now i'm going to
step back out into python and just need
to step over again so i can see my
variable so now we can see our bit array
over here and you might notice that it
doesn't actually show with the beta rays
just as the bitrate object so that's
actually one of the limitations of this
debugger that I'll talk about in a
little bit but for now if we actually
want to see what's in there I'll just
manually call the wrapper and we can see
the battery up the bits so now now that
I'm out of this test actually suppose I
decided that actually want to know how
exactly this is stored under the hood
inside the structure that's
in this thing so we have something for
that too if you go to if I go to the
same menu there's another option here
which you might have guessed by now what
it does now I'm going to enable that and
now I can expand my array and there we
go so again it figured out automatically
what type what c-type this Python object
is and we can inspect the members we can
see that it has four bits we can see the
end Ennis's one it's actually began in a
curious enough I can actually look at
other things too so these things as you
can see you can I can expand and Luke
say at the type so it'll nests but now
suppose so this is the actual buffer of
RA and this is the first element of the
buffer so suppose I want to check that
those beats are really there it's not
like to do some bit mangling hear bits
willing to actually get those four bits
so I'm going to do an ad watch and look
at this so we are still in in the middle
of a Python frame and this is actually
so this this here but is a Python
expression and below is a c++ expression
built our evaluated side-by-side and i'm
just going to extract the top four bits
here so I'll just
to the bitwise end and I'll do shift
adds 10 which is exactly 10 10 in
bitwise operations awesome so now that
we've seen this stuff another
interesting question is what happens to
exceptions in this model so for this let
me actually start try another tests or
just above this one we can see you
noticed the chest that an exception has
been raised if inappropriate values are
passed so I'm going to stop this and set
a breakpoint here and this is the one I
want to run so again we'll have to wait
a little bit until it actually loads and
proof of this thing is something that
we're working on it's unfortunately not
as good as but like but we certainly are
improving it and future releases so so
far so good and I'm just going to go to
exception settings and tell it to break
on all Python exceptions and we'll just
run run this thing and see what happens
okay so I've got my exception it says it
gives me the type the Python top of the
exception it gives me the error message
text but most importantly if you look at
what's behind it it actually stops in
native code so it stopped at the exact
line that called a set the set error API
set string in this case so we are
physically in the local stack we can
inspect local variables basically we
have the full context of why exactly
that exception happened in native code
before it leaks to python code where
balu solid context so that's that's more
or less the it with the DEM apart if we
have a little bit of time left I'll show
something else
interesting now I'm going to get back to
a few more things that are like to
discuss so to recap the features briefly
so you can step from Python code or C++
or C++ to python freely you can set
breakpoints in both at the same time and
you can see them being hit you can see
inspect both patency frames on your
stack at any given moment you can view
Python presentations of any pie object
on your native code and in when you and
Python the reverse you can see the
structs begging your viewer specific
values and you can see Python exceptions
at the point where they raised a native
code actually finally if you can
actually win see them if they never go
to python because sometimes you have
this native code throw an exception and
then immediately catch in and you can
actually track those things so now I'm
going to talk about the less exciting
stuff which is limitations that come
with all this unfortunately the Power
has its price so the problem here is
that because we have native debugger
alongside Python debugger native debug
your limits what the Python debugger can
do and specifically this means that the
patented bugger can't just run Python
code inside the process it does actually
know if it's safe to do so it can be
stopped in the middle of Python
interpreter God knows who holds the gill
there's all kind of stuff to deal with
so the bugger the Python debugger does
thing the hard way and this means it
actually parses the objects directly in
memory it reads the bytes of those
objects to figure out what they are and
what it relates to you is that you only
get full support the kind of you expect
from you know a Python debugger if the
debugger knows the type you're looking
at and this is something that we wish we
already seen in practice when we've
looked at the bit array and it just
showed you know it's an object of type
data rate because it didn't know what
bit array actually is all it can tell is
it's this this is its type so you've
seen the workaround that I've used
to handle that generally speaking this
means that there is a limited subset of
the Python language that you get in
locals and a special and watch like you
can't just write arbitrary path and
expressions and expect them to work
basically whichever subset we actually
implemented is what you get and we have
a detailed page explaining what exactly
works and doesn't work and in practice
you'll find that actually sometimes
those expressions do work generally
speaking when you adjust debug in Python
you can expect things to work as you are
but when you're in native code in the
middle of like a function or something
then you're going to see the much more
limited experience so my wrapper worked
because i was debugging Python code so
what this means a particular down or it
means that non pi arrays don't have any
special support so if you see an umpire
in the code you're just going to see
numpy object so obviously this is a kind
of big item and this is definitely
something that will work and add support
in the next major release and while i'm
on at this point i would actually like
to for everyone who's interested in this
thing we are very we would very much
like you guys to give us your feedback
on what things you think we should
prioritize support for and our project
is open source is on github so please
you know file feature requests and give
us what you the list of things list of
tabs you want to see support it and
hopefully in the future we'll have some
extensibility points there so people can
actually write their own visualizers for
you know and not wait for us to do this
but for the time being this is where it
is and in addition to those things
there's also some special requirements
for this debugging mode which might not
be the same that you're used to with
regular Python the buggers so first of
all let me get a get this out of the way
so it's not to dwell on it so this is
unfortunately for now at least windows
only sorry about that it's not the case
we really really want you to use windows
so much it's really because for the
thing to work well it needs a native
debugger that's cooperative that knows
that other debuggers exist and that
provides us with the means to actually
work together with it and visual studio
action has this thing built from it they
permit from the grounds app and
unfortunately we are not aware of
anything similar on Linux or OS X so the
effort required to implement this there
is much much higher and but definitely
if this is to change absolutely would
love to do this for Linux in the future
so uh speaking of Python versions
because of what I told earlier you know
parts and objects in memory that's kind
of stuff you might expect that there are
some limitations there you will be right
so first of all on the versions so this
only supports C Python so if using
something more exotic like if it's pi PI
it's not supported sorry maybe
eventually and in terms of versions all
versions at 27 and all versions starting
with 33 and above are supported and we
actually try to do to be more flexible
about this stuff so as you know there's
many minor versions of Python there are
things like the bug builds you might
want to build your own so what we do
actually is we use debug symbols for the
Python binaries to dynamically compute
the object layouts runtime so this gives
us much more flexibility and this means
that all the things that have listed
actually work like if you go and build
your own custom Python it will be
supported and even if you like to eat
compiler flags you change alignment you
change structure pack and it will still
work but that means that we do need
symbols to the bug so where do you get
that stuff so if we are talking about
stockbyte and if you're just using the
you know you go to buy the morgue and
download that thing you can download the
symbols from there as well they actually
publish all that all the thing on the
release pages for every release and we
have dog page explaining how to where to
go how to get it how to unpack you know
how to register it properly actually if
you're using 35
which is awesome by the way there is
some work that Microsoft specifc
aaliyah's contributed to the new windows
installer for Python 35 that makes it
much simpler because if you do a custom
install you have an option for you to do
it all for you so it'll automatically
just take a check box and you get
everything set up for you right away if
you're using a custom distro things get
more complicated because some distros to
publish the symbols some distros
actually use the stock Python symbols so
those just work and I was using to win
Python during the demo and it just works
others unfortunately do not do this and
if they do not do this then we do not
support them so we hope that given the
utility of this thing and especially if
it you know as it gets more popular that
it would be more encouragement for
distribution containers to actually do
this thing and to publish symbols and
some of them have already started doing
so and you can really help us here if
you go you know you go and try your
favorite distro and if it doesn't work
then please file a bug on them and ask
them to pub to do this thing because
it's really easy for them there's no
reason not to do this and it will enable
this scenario for you and for all the
other users so looks like we'll have a
little bit more time so I'm going to do
a quick demo or something related and
you might some of you might already be
wondering about that so let me open this
different projects and yeah this is
exactly what it looks like so I'm just
going to start that
and step in and yeah this is seven and
again set breakpoints and they've been
here so unfortunately it it's not really
very pretty still because you can still
see it's a native frame and the
variables are not very pretty looking
but you can still see things because of
the Python view so you can see for
instance that the key here is to and
this is definitely another area which is
which we would very much like to improve
supporting in the future and give you
proper by proper size and stepping you
know give you code completion
intellisense for all that stuff and
hopefully in the next major release will
have something along those lines so
that's everything that I wanted to show
for the day and I would like to remind
that the product all the things that
I've shown that they are free so visuals
to the community edition this works with
community edition it also works with
express so go ahead download it play
with it python to us a visual studio
free open source free software on github
we take pull requests would be awesome i
forget some and now be happy to answer
any of your questions please
so which ones were interested about in
okay so so yeah so the question was
whether anaconda distributions work with
the thing so the answer is unfortunately
they're on the list which do not and
would really love that to change in the
future yep that's a good opportunity
absolutely any other questions sure
sure so the first question was about the
performance so this is a so this is a in
some cases this is much slower than what
you're used to and you're probably
already used to python debuggers been
generally slower than just running code
and the extreme case here is that it
took five minutes for the program to
start and it was it was running like at
five percent of its normal speed so
actually a it's kind of like there's a
way to answer it quickly so I'll need to
explain a little bit so the actual
performance penalty right now is for
loading a new piece of pieces of code
and specifically if you want to get
technical it's my new code objects get
created as when the slowdown happens so
the startup type is the start start
start up time is so long in some cases
if you basically import something that
imports a bunch of stuff that has a lot
of like small functions because when
those functions are you know being
created you it basically poses a lot so
once that is done you are actually
looking at a much faster experience and
typically it where I should be faster
than a regular Python two-bagger once
all the code objects are there once all
the modules are loaded so this is it is
indeed it's a tricky problem I don't
want to get too technical here into why
we are like doing things like that but
it's definitely on my top priority list
to fix for the next release so for the
time being unfortunately that's a
limitation that's that's there and that
you should be aware of and the second
question was how do you actually made it
so that you can debug siphon in any
other pie epyx file instead of just
looking at the C code so actually
there's no special support in
either of those tools whatsoever for
siphon it's all just native debugger
doing its thing but the trick here is
that siphon itself has a command line
option when you run it too I think it's
called line numbers the line directives
or something like that and when you use
that it outputs line directors in
generated say code and the native
debugger actually is aware of those
things and it will show you the it what
molecular basically bring out the pyx
file instead of bringing up the COC bus
class file and it will map breakpoints
back and forth so if you use that then
you will see what you've seen here oh
you so the other question was so you
wouldn't be able to look at the local
variables so actually that was not quite
true because you steal the local
variables still show from the generated
sukkot so you see exactly what the sea
frame is and so you see all those
temporaries things that are there did I
answer your question um anyone else yep
please ah there is no special support
for boost insofar as it's still a native
code you would still be able to step
into it you would have to step through
boost itself before it calls your code
and there is something in visual studio
in the gnu debugger where you can
basically mark a header as like you know
the code that shouldn't be debugged and
then it automatically steps through it I
don't remember if they have a dog the
commutation I think they have a blog
post explain how you do it and I think
that with this thing you could
significantly cut down on that and you
know that amount you spend doing this oh
and by the way while we read one other
thing I should mention is that aside
from C extensions this also supports
stepping through C types so if you do
see types call to dll you can step
through the call it will end up in the
dealer any other questions
great okay thank you